Dude, we had our two Thanksgiving's ago.
We had two hours at my sister's house.
Yeah, I saw one last night
actually. Did you? Yeah. It
was pretty, no, not last night.
Night before last.
It was pretty fucking cool.
I pulled into the driveway and an owl
took off. Who was big too? It's gross.
I think owls, the meet the uh Oh,
you ate them, you saying? Yeah,
but you guys eight hours.
Yeah, that's legal.
He's probably shouldn't say
that on a podcast. Well,
I didn't have a lot. We'll used to have
a joke about it and I didn't have a lot.
Man. I have no job. The guy even spit it
out. I'm not even joking. Yeah. Clinton,
when you smoked that weed and they had to,
they didn't have all the things.
They don't have a lot of meat on
him. It, I fucking know. Like owls.
They're predators. They're
important. Yeah. You don't
have rats everywhere. Yeah,
but how, you know they're,
I think they're violent.
Then they're dirty and they get this owls,
whoever did their PR,
you notice everything's, they're smart
and they can read and they're like, yeah,
they had a good PR, right? Yeah. Look
at that. We only got one up, Jim,
but see how much little meat is on
them. You think there's more? Look,
he's kidding. He's kidding folks. He's
not eating owls. The one in the middle,
it looks like it's from another
planet, you know? Yeah. Yeah,
and that's what, that's what it really
looks like. That's what it looks like.
Fluff little alien raptor creature.
I was like a crab.
It looks like a crab.
I was driving home on one,
was flying above me on the
road and dropped a rabbit.
He had got a rabbit and jacked.
It was flying with the
rabbit and as he was flying,
just decided like maybe decided the car
was too close to him or it was too loud
or something like that. I just
dropped that rabbits it, fuck it.
And I stopped the car and to check it
out, I was like, whoa. That's flirt.
And really it sounds like
flirting LFL or dropping a rabbit.
It's your feet a bitch. It's
ready to fuck. Probably. Yeah,
like an offering look like God for
you more with that. I can't, maybe
they're predators, man. We never
thought of him growing up as predators.
Yeah, they told us they
were wise. They had that,
that Monica like fucking
like Budd Friedman. Yeah.
You need the Improv. I remember
that. I like that. Planter's peanuts.